hi there everyone can I just say quick
thanks to everyone who watched my last
video in which I set myself the slightly
bonkers challenge of rolling a Yahtzee a
one roll Yahtzee that is you've all had
a lot to say about it and I think the
main thing has been a little bit of
disappointment with my lack of
enthusiasm when I finally achieved my
goal I have done it mister tapes about
to end but I've done it I have rolled a
Yahtzee and amazingly five of you have
already sent me videos of you guys
performing a one roll Yahtzee let's have
a quick look this first one came from
David who was obviously a bit concerned
about waking anyone up in his house so
he had to do it in silence but then here
we go a magic moment and he rolls all
twos for his Yahtzee well done David he
did it in silence and he tells me it
took him one hour and 44 minutes let's
have a look at another one de moda
coaster tells me it took just 328
attempts and here it is like me all
threes
Miranda Richards apparently took 25
minutes watched by her pet cats before
this moment all fours but that's a
Yahtzee and the odds are one in 1296 but
I've saved the best for last here are
two more both by people called Richard
here's the first one Richard Moyer here
in Canada apparently took two and a half
hours and 1743 rolls until this happened
oh yeah I did it
Kilauea rolling away yeah on Three's
yeah and I can forgive that reaction and
here's the last one another rather
excited Yahtzee roller
yes oh not sure how many rolls it took
but a pretty excited reaction thanks a
lot to those people and if you want to
have a try send it in there's the email
address I'll use the video that's for
sure and if you want to watch my
original Yahtzee video now the link will
be somewhere on the screen using
annotations or under the video anyway
better get back to work